aujourd'hui le prix du pétrole a accusé
un certain recul avec un baril à 73
dollars
mais les tensions au proche orient font
redouter de nouvelles flambées depuis
plusieurs années de nombreux pays se
sont dotées de réserves souterraines
pour faire face à une éventuelle crise
et pénurie pétrole la france par exemple
dispose ainsi d'un immense site de
stockage près de manosque au coeur même
du parc naturel du luberon
frédéric montel guillaume viard manosque
vingt mille habitants autant de cigales
est une richesse méconnue devinez
laquelle
c'est l'effet de moi lorsque je sais pas
du tout de qualité à l'école ce n'est
pas l'épaule pétrole et jamais ne lui
dit rien ils ont cherché mais jamais
trop épais 3 les îles jamais trouvées
toujours stockés à quelques kilomètres
de là le parc du luberon
au royaume des aigles et des sangliers
de l'or noir la plus importantes
réserves de pétrole en france
qu'est ce qu'il ya là sous nos pieds
vous voyez la tête depuis trente mètres
à peu près nous séparent de cette es2
puis de l'autre côté 30 m eh bien vous
avez à 400 mètres de profondeur 500
mille mètres cubes de gaz eau des puits
comme celui là il y en a 28
de quoi alimenter les français pendant
quinze jours en cas d'urgence seulement
on s'en serviraient sur décision du
gouvernement en cas de rupture
d'approvisionnement pour une raison
quelconque en cas de conflit en cas
d'incident technique majeur sur un
approvisionnement
on s'en est servi par exemple il ya un
an pour
soulager nos amis américains après les
l'ouragan katrina qui avait mis hors
service un certain nombre de raffineries
le site a été bâtie dans les années 60
avec une technique originale pour
l'époque
en injectant de l'eau dans des couches
de sel ont créé un coffre-fort naturel
facile d'accès pour le pétrole est aussi
grand que la tour eiffel
moi je préfère avoir ces stockages qui
sont enterrés dans des cavités de seine
et qu'elle ne pollue pas si vous voulez
la vision une grosse pincée de sel
beaucoup de pétrole
une bonne recette pour la mairie leur
noire rapportent chaque année près de
deux millions d'euros à manosque en taxe
professionnelle